y
[Música]
con resaca amaneció este lunes plaza
italia el centro neurálgico de las
manifestaciones y también de la gran
celebración que se vivió en la noche del
25 de octubre en todo chile cuando se
conocieron los resultados electorales
que mostraron un apabullante victoria de
la prueba en las urnas un 78 por ciento
de los chilenos decidieron sepultar para
siempre la constitución heredada de la
dictadura de augusto pinochet los
encargados de redactar una nueva carta
magna- serán ciudadanos chilenos de a
pie 155 que deberán de ser seleccionados
en unas elecciones el próximo mes de
abril y que contarán con entre 9 meses y
un año para escribir una nueva
constitución será la primera vez en la
historia que y también en el mundo que
una constitución sea escrita en un
cincuenta por ciento por mujeres y
también se espera que haya espacio
reservado para los pueblos originarios
muchos desafíos para satisfacer las
demandas sociales que piden los chilenos
a una nueva carta magna
[Música]
pese a la distancia geográfica no se
puede obviar la influencia que ha tenido
en las últimas décadas chile en colombia
el sistema económico neoliberal al que
los chilenos han dicho basta fue
inspiración para otros países de la
región especialmente colombia sobre todo
en lo que tiene que ver con el sistema
de salud y pensiones
de hecho el estallido social de octubre
de 2019 en chile- tuvo su réplica en
colombia el 21 de noviembre en un paro
nacional que dio lugar a las protestas
más fuertes de los últimos años en el
país
en aquel momento voces como la del
actual alcalde de medellín daniel
quintero pidieron una nueva carta magna
sin embargo la actual constitución
colombiana cumplirá en 2021 30 años y
nació entonces por la iniciativa de un
movimiento estudiantil llamado todavía
podemos salvar a colombia muchas voces
consideran que la actual ley fundamental
colombiana sigue teniendo un gran
contenido social sin embargo denuncian
su aplicación una desvirtuación del
contenido original que los chilenos
esperan no repetir
[Música]
el gobierno de nicolás maduro eligió a
la asamblea nacional constituyente el 30
de julio de 2017 espaldas de la
oposición y la comunidad internacional
que consideró a esa votación como
ilegítima negro convocó la constituyente
sin celebrar previamente un referendo
consultivo el mandatario explicó hace
tres años que la institución colaboraría
con la imposición de la paz en venezuela
agitada en ese momento por masivas
protestas contra el gobierno por la
anulación judicial de la opositora
asamblea nacional la enee se tenía como
propósito original la redacción de una
nueva constitución nacional y no cumplió
su cometido sus principales rasgos han
sido la aprobación de leyes favorables
al gobierno de nicolás maduro
originalmente la constituyente duraría
sólo dos años pero ha sido extendido
hasta el 31 de diciembre de 2020 su cese
coincidirá con las elecciones
parlamentarias del 6 de diciembre en las
que no participarán 27 partidos aliados
al opositor juan guaidó
[Música]